because every screen rod I think this is
really true finishes a screenplay thinks
it's brilliant that people do it all the
time and they usually write me do Chris
Krebs a lot of writers hate because they
collect but my script is different from
them you have some characters sitting in
a diner and somebody goes ketchup what's
that about that is a one way to put your
audience to sleep very very quickly the
other thing is that what's real is more
I think a character with no inner life I
think is boring and the story's going to
be really boring and nobody's going to
be interested and be bored to tears
anytime
one thing where he said to me was he
said don't look outside yourself look
within and so it's again finding I
divided sunny there was one time when he
and I was sitting together and I said I
just figure out what business you're in
I said not writer I said you're in the
very Bradbury business and he said yes
that's exactly right
and what he saw what he was doing was
creating something that no one else
could create and he told me that he
spent he wrote every day for ten years
before he wrote a single line a single
word that was uniquely his and then one
day he sat down and he wrote the words
the lake and he wrote a short story
based on the time when he was a little
boy when he was eight years old he and a
little girl friend who was seven when
swimming in Lake Michigan and he came
out and she never did she drowned and
her strength had her coming back as a
ghost and he told me that when he
finished the story tears were streaming
down his face and he knew he'd written
something that no one else could have
written it came specifically from his
experience in his soul and he said it
took it and it took another two years of
writing every day before he could write
something again that was uniquely his
and they got to where he could do it
again and again and again and he became
Ray Bradbury because he was determined
to do that and so I thought that was a
great lesson to say okay what are you
creating what can you create that isn't
something that's just an imitation what
others are doing
but that's unique to you that no one
else could have created that you create
something fresh in the world that's
truthful and meaningful and and then you
know you've done something what's doing
so that's that's been a great
inspiration to me
my underlying philosophy of all
storytelling whether you're a novelist
or screenwriter movie maker TV writer
whatever it might be is that your
primary goal as a storyteller must be to
elicit emotion you must create an
emotional experience for the audience if
it's a movie or a play for the reader if
you're a screenwriter and you have to
get get it read so you can get the movie
made or if you're a novelist or whatever
so your primary goal has to be to create
emotion
not that cliche right what you know
because I've never written what I quote
unquote know I write fantastical worlds
and and and and and supernatural stories
and all of that but write what you feel
and write what's in your heart and write
something that means something to you
and you know I I was a script reader for
God probably a decade and I and the and
and I was reading seven eight scripts a
week and the rare one was the great
script and when you found that that was
a very exciting day at the office
and sometimes the really terrible
scripts were kind of they were funny
because they were so god-awful but the
ones that got really exhausting and
really innovating as a script reader
who's sitting there and asked to read a
script synopsize that write a comment
about it then pick up another one and
read it and it's not were the ones that
you could tell were written by people
who were looking at what last year's hit
was and trying to imitate it and those
were deadly and they were they weren't
good they weren't bad they were safe and
mediocre and any writer any young writer
any old writer anyone who's just
starting to write anything write
something that you feel write write
write write something that comes from
the heart and and and people may not
think that Beetlejuice is a personal
movie it's an intensely personal movie
it was intensely personal for Michael me
and and you know I I didn't know I had a
theme until I had enough work to realize
I had a theme and almost everything I've
written are about broken families who
are put back together in some bizarre
way but there but but because I came
from a broken family and and what and
and so so
that there's a I like to think that my
work has a sense of heart in a sense of
compassion and a sense of humanity in it
no matter how bizarre it is no matter
how weird the world's get and and you
got you got to write something that you
feel on something that you have some
passion for or just why do it it's too
hard it's just it's not an easy job and
and I personally can't imagine saying
well this was a hit now so I'm going to
I'm going to write my version that I
don't really it's not really what I care
about what I feel but I can imitate it
well enough I can't imagine spending a
year of your life doing that but people
do it all the time and they usually
write mediocre scrubs
enough story again it's that old thing
characters can be wonderful dialogue can
be sparkling and even funny as heck but
if the story lays there just flat as a
pancake that story is not going anywhere
it's it's a weak story
I'm the slowest reader in the world like
it will take me six hours to read a
script I don't know why that I've kind
of read it out loud in my head or
something but what happens because of
that is that I am stuck in every single
moment in that script for a really long
time so I notice really quickly when
something takes too long where a quick
your reader will probably just go like
oh here's a here's a page of whatever
now just continue reading on I get angry
if I'm on a page that doesn't know what
at once and I don't know why I'm in that
scene right now
and I hope the right this felt very bad
but I kind of called the writer
personally responsible with wasting my
time which really isn't their fault
because I'm just a slow reader but at
least after reading it I have a very
clear and it might be completely off
objectively but I had a very clear idea
where I felt the script worked or didn't
work and then I just apply I'm a big big
believer in formula as always working in
classic narrative structure like from
Aristotle although I think Robert McKee
is dreams I know a lot of people think
he's too formulaic and ease whatever but
I think that most of the weaknesses in
narratives when it can't hold your your
attention that is because it doesn't
adhere to a certain narrative structure
three-act structure 5.x structure
whatever it is that is ingrained in us
as human beings you know so I work a lot
with question marks for example at what
at what moment at this moment in the
script what are the question marks that
I as an audience and burning to have
answered that make me turn the page why
am i interested in continuing this and a
lot of time you'll realize there is no
question mark that people are just
having coffee right now and you know
it's a problem in a prospect what we're
talking about earlier which is conflict
and stakes cost drama is conflict and
stakes that also means that you don't
know what the outcome of something will
be so there is a kind of internal
magnetism and a structure from moment to
moment
that I think you have a it's very easy
to get a good feeling for that I do not
be distracted by that's maybe another
thing I'm not a very visual person as
and I don't see the script in my head
you know at all feel the story I read
the story I get a feeling for the
characters I don't see images and I
think a lot of other people that do see
the images are kind of seduced by that
and don't necessarily see that the story
is weak you know that the that the
cornerstones of the story are not as
powerful as they should be but because I
don't have that visual at all to
distract me I'm always after the moments
that don't live up to the full potential
in what they are trying to do and that's
a very abstract thing that doesn't
matter if that happens on a boat or in
space or on whatever is you know it's
always the why should the audience be at
the edge on the edge of their seat right
now what are they wondering about what
do they want to find out why do they
care what do they identify with those
things you know so it's almost a
mathematical structure which helps me
look because it is basically more or
less to start the same starting point
for almost every script which of course
a lot of writers hate because they go
like but my script is different from
them that's good it is different in
subject matter and content but in the
underlying audience expectation and the
rhythm than an audience has in consuming
a story it's not different it's good
meat that's met with the same
expectations so you have to see it
through that lens to know how an
audience is going to react to it
there's about creativity and originality
- I think originality comes from being
curious
because the more curious you are about
something the more you know about
something and so the more you can avoid
copying something right it's I think the
people who write cliche what cliche
writing because they don't know what's
been done before so they go to them it's
new so they go oh they think it's good
but people who know and they've seen it
a hundred times because they're curious
I will say it's cliche because they've
seen it a hundred times
cooking the reader just so important
there regardless of what you're writing
I just think you know for me if I'm not
really feeling a buck fifty and I will
put a lot of books down but fifteen
hundred pages is a long time and if I'm
not feeling it and you'd be surprised
how many books I think don't really work
on that level I may not finish it and
especially when you're dealing with more
commercial genres it becomes even more
important younger readers I think it
becomes even more important that said I
don't think you need to rush or
sacrifice the storytelling to make it so
hooky in a certain respect like I
personally wouldn't want to do that but
I think getting into the story right
away
having something exciting happen in the
beginning in my book I chose to write a
prologue that showed kind of what
happened before when the surface of the
earth was destroyed so I told it from if
you can imagine the president's
daughters point of view as they're
evacuating the White House so young girl
being evacuated and I because I did that
and for a couple reasons but one was I
wanted have something really exciting
and really relatable that happened right
off the bat because I think that that
will cook you in and make you want to
read more but there's other ways to hook
somebody you're like having a great
character having central mystery is
something I teach about a lot which is
it doesn't mean that it has to obviously
there's a mystery genre where the whole
story is crafted around a mystery but
that said you can have a story that has
smaller mysteries that are revealed in
the beginning of a book a good example
is in The Hunger Games they talk about
the reaping which is the big thing
happens right away in The Hunger Games
but they say the word the reaping seven
or eight times before they finally tell
you what it is and you find out fairly
early in the story but still you're kind
of reading like oh what is this what is
this thing that's happening was this big
event so I think that's another way to
kind of get somebody interested and
trying to figure out what's going on
and I got the script and I was really
excited to read it and the first page I
opened it up and it wasn't even
formatted properly and I read the first
page and and they weren't writing in
proper sentences and I had to slog
through this thing to figure out what
they were trying to say and I gave up
after a couple of pages because they
just did abused me basically they'd
stolen my time they'd wasted my time on
something that wasn't a professional
product that could never be produced in
its current state and maybe if I had
forced myself to read the whole script
there would have been a nugget in there
that was a great idea and with some work
you know I could have pounded the script
into shape and tried to do something
with it but who has that time and who
knows you could get to the end of this
hundred and twenty page script it takes
you two hours out of a very busy day and
you get to the end they could all have
been crap even even though that one
sentence pitch they sent me was a good
idea so you got to be sure and you can't
just read it yourself and think it's
great other people have to be telling
you it's great
so you see this a lot I mean this
she writing so you get like a character
description well you know I read this
all the time you know she's beautiful or
handsome you know it's the same house
nice and it says right I mean yeah
that's the same old have you've seen the
hundred times you know she's got to be
little more creative
massive central character that kids
killed more scripts than just about
anything I've ever seen and week story
and PASOK central character they go
together they really go to get fit
together to a passive central character
is a a hero or heroine you know the lead
down the middle who doesn't really do
anything and life and the story happen
to them they do not happen to anything
or anyone and that is that is a one way
to put your audience to sleep very very
quickly
audience heroes have to be active having
an active hero who has a clear want is
definitely a huge thing that I work with
writers on every strong story starts
with a trigger incident or inciting
incident as many people tournament it
pushes the central character into a
powerful dilemma then the choice that is
made in the dilemma is what defines the
external role for the a story and every
obstacle escalating obstacle in all is
lost moments need to link back to that
choice and when the goal isn't clear the
story doesn't work because everything
needs to link back to like there are
countless on features as well as TV
shows we're in the middle of the story
you have no idea what's in spare too
long like you've lost it because the
actions and obstacles aren't linked to
the desire and we lose a sense of what
the desire was so when you do that story
doesn't work and and very often all
writers will write a passive hero that
isn't taking action
with no inner life I think is boring you
know I think if I think if for me I
think if the character is having some
inner life that makes sense
you know whether that inner life is
subtext or whether that inner life is in
conflict with his public life or her
public life you know that's interesting
to me you know I don't know I think it
really depends on the kind of story it
is and you know you know every I guess
you know to use a comparison to like
making a meal I think every meal is
different you know every meal demands
different kind of ingredient if there's
something about that character that
tells me that either that person isn't
telling everything about his life or her
life or there's something about that
person that what he or she is doing you
know in front of people is different
from what they're doing behind the
scenes for me that's interesting
every scene is a power grab everybody
wants to take control of the situation
in whatever way that means to them and
so how are they sort of secretly
jockeying for position you know like he
and I do like which of us it we're all
just worried we're worried about which
of us look smarter see that's what this
whole interview has been the other thing
that you said about the quote be the
desires on the part of the character I
was thinking I know you said there's a
lot more than two but two more I would
think about as the writer besides what
were the two you said what does the
character what don't know what that the
two different objectives yeah the vision
what I broke down Michael is what I call
the public objective right in other
words if I asked anybody in this room
now what are you doing here what do you
want what's your objective right now we
could talk about what during this
interview that's our public objective
then there's underneath that deep under
there is a private objective which may
not even be recognized well yeah that's
what I maybe in the unconscious what's
driving that character to try to do that
right and one way I would look at it is
not quite the same as a desire is to ask
what is the character hiding from the
other person consciously what is she
hiding from him and what is she hiding
from herself what's the thing that she's
not yet aware of that is really driving
her and you know underneath especially
in the first half or 3/4 of the movie
towards the end you'd hope that all that
would come to the surface but deception
and secrecy are very very powerful in
telling a story because they add a whole
new layer of conflict they get into this
inner journey stuff and though and the
more conflict on the more layers the
more you're going to pull in your
audience that's good I like to hide
anything I didn't see because I was into
that yeah the subconscious or the
unconscious or the you know unaware of
but the hiding and deception is secrecy
that's good I'm going to steal that can
I steal that huh sure I'll get yours
like it well you can still use it
I've got taking it forever okay you want
to share it you don't want to steal no
I'm not going to sit back as long as
we're clear that Maya gel is going to
look better I'll give you credit for it
okay good okay because we know my stated
objective is to look smarter I think we
yes I'm trying and I'm trying to help
you with I appreciate that I'll help you
think you're winning here let's move on
that was great let's move on
did you know for instance there are only
four viable goals in all of narrative
screenwriting and the vocals are yeah
when stop escape or retrieve so okay
you've got an idea for a character your
hero or heroine great you've got an idea
and they have okay now what is it they
want what they've got to have a goal to
pursue right well it has to fall into
the category of winds DAF escape or
retrieve now these are big categories
and there are many versions of each
woman many permutations of each one so
it's not like it's that cut and dried
but it will appear to a lot of people
like it's that's to cut and dried for me
but the point is this
there's only those four because those
four share something in common they all
provide a visible physical
three-dimensional goal for a motion
picture that will result in a physical
climax and obligatory scene it precludes
the use of internal goals and that's one
of the things people have to get over an
internal goal that's great and it is
separate from what drives the movie you
need a physical visible goal each one of
those four goals has a finish line a
visible finish line and a goal like well
they want to feel better about
themselves
that doesn't work on film it just
doesn't work
personally I like to try to get to know
the character in my own mind know the
characters enough in my own mind so that
I know how they're going to behave or
react to whatever I throw at them to me
it's like if you can understand the
characters and sometimes that's why it's
so easy for excuse me sometimes that's
why it's better to base a character on
somebody you know or yourself because
you know when you based on your brother
or your mother or best friend or
yourself because then you know how that
person talks how that person is going to
react to something and then you don't
have to make everything up otherwise the
burden of you as a writer to make up
everything that happens is is a lot
whereas if you know who the character is
an example always use if somebody's
walking down the street and a guy jumps
out with a knife and says give me your
wallet if it's if it's me as a character
I probably get on my hands and knees and
start crying and you know whatever if
it's Jason Bourne you know a fight chase
ensues you know what I mean so so
knowing the character first I think is
helpful and then yeah I think all
writers probably have there in their
mind a handful of not everything a
handful of things that are supposed to
happen they're going to drive the story
but I I prefer probably to my detriment
to only think out the whole thing to a
certain degree I try not to have
everything set and I tried it maybe I
have that I have certainly maybe that
first deck I know what the inciting
things are going to be but then I like
to sort of let the characters in some
way tell me what the next scene is as
opposed to making them do something that
I've already add any more interesting
things have come out of that and in the
times where I've had like a lot of us
have an ending in our mind at times
where I've had a definite ending like
the whole reason for writing the script
was because I got the last scene in my
head by the time I get there neva tably
it's not that because the characters
have grown and the situation has taken
on some sort of life of its own so by
the time it gets that thing
doesn't make sense anymore they would
have been an imposed ending or an
artificial ending and so I think the
writing can be a lot easier the more
real those characters become for you
all of these characters there's only 14
that that help you create a plot that
help move a story forward and any other
character that the particular writer
wants to plot you know I really like
this character you know that kind of
interesting and peppy and zippy and they
talk funny and I like it
if they do not serve the story if they
do not help drive the plot forward get
random axle cut them lose them because
they have to serve a function
the heart and soul of this it's a really
interesting screenplay it's a thriller
action invention thriller but what is at
the heart soul of it that the audience
can grab on to and identify with my
feeling is the audience doesn't really
want to watch a big action-adventure
film but they want me to watch it be
thrilled to watch it one that's well
done but they want to connect with the
people and what the people's journey is
and what the people's struggles are what
the people's epiphanies are or
disappointments are in the
transformation of characters that's what
they want to they want to connect with
the aspect of that story that relates to
their own lives which may be very subtle
only very very powerful but we have to
identify that so talking with these
these two writers yesterday that was the
goal is to find that and then once we
can identify that with the writers then
we could eat all of us can ask you to is
it in the script is it clear in the
script that that's what it is but first
of all you got to feel what it is and
that's why many times looking at a
script you can feel it's not there but
rather than trying to cover it up or
pretend it's there or soon that it's
there or just insert something there go
back to the writers go back to the
people who had the original idea and
find out what that is and then try to
identify that and that is actually for a
director that's what's going to guide
you through the entire rest of the
process that's what the movie is all
about this movie is all about this
character who's fighting these struggles
wasn't fighting these aspects of himself
in the world around him and his family
or his work or whatever he's fighting
and that what gets revealed through that
process is what this man or this woman
is going through that we can identify
with so you got to get bets early then
the process of the rewrites re-examining
script is how can we get that in how can
we make that clear to the audience also
clear to the actors really important so
the actors can see it the actors who are
playing as parts going to attach
themselves to
ask in jump is where we as the audience
jump onto the screen and become the
protagonist in the story and a good
story has some sort of a fantasy so it
doesn't have to be a positive fantasy
that we want to explore in our life so
we skin jump and we are Eliot riding his
bicycle with et and it flies you know
and that is like one of those moments
where if you were to turn the camera on
the audience and watch would watch the
audience they would all be just
overjoyed because we're all Elliott in
that scene for that moment and if we're
looking at a movie that's a we can
become Indiana Jones and do the amazing
adventure thing and we basically jump
from the audience onto the screen which
means we need a character to jump into
and a good story is about a character
that fulfills some sort of dream
fulfillment some sort of fantasy the
audience has and a the reason why film
is a hit is because it ends up hitting
the dream fulfillment element of a lot
of people and so if you can figure out
the zeitgeist of what the audience what
people are dreaming about right now
that's that thing that's going to pull
us onto the screen but it doesn't have
to be a positive thing often I did a
film to our class here and the film noir
often jumps us into people that do bad
things because we all sometimes secretly
want to do bad things but we can't so
you know we all want to you know there's
a lot of movies about career criminals
because we all sometimes want to break
the law there are a lot of movies about
people that do terrible awful things
that kill people the two horrible bosses
that kill their bosses are trying to do
bad things because we have that thing
going on inside of us that's the dream
fulfillment of that story so a good
movie is dream fulfillment to the
audience the audience fantasizes about
something we hopefully as part of that
audience as members of that audience we
fantasize about some of those things to
you a weird movie is when somebody has
their dream fulfilled and you go what
kind of a sick weirdo is that dream and
you see those sometimes and
what's going on here
but but a good story is going to take
going to take action it's going to allow
the audience to jump into that character
and then take that character on an
adventure to be a good adventure it
could be a bad adventure but we're going
to go along with that story and it's so
that means there's going to be a great
conflict in there someplace
that means often you know the things
that often happens is romance of some
sort of another because even if it's you
know ET is a bonus dog story but the
dogs an alien and there is no more
unconditional love than from your dog or
you know I don't know your cat loves you
but your dog loves you no matter what so
that's something we can fantasize about
we can get into that story we can
understand that story and jump in to
Eliot's life with ET and you know it's
the guy that brings the kid to bring
some of the pets that you know mom
doesn't want and has to hide it in the
closet and you know all those things you
know I found a stray dog
but the stray dogs an alien and now the
dog catcher wants the dog catchers keys
he's the guy from the government so it's
basically taking that story and finding
them you take on that story because he
that could have been in just a dog story
but by making it the alien we're now
telling the story we've already heard
and telling a story that's new that's
different that gives us a different
experience than we've had before the
hero is the audience you build that you
build a story so that the hero is it
with lots of flaws and everything fine
yes make them human but they have
certain qualities character of character
and of circumstance they have to be
brave that is absolutely essential but
you can put them in you know unfair
injury we care about people who are
being unjustly dealt with they're in a
situation of danger they're funny
they have a sense of humor that always
helps loved by other people there is
this kind of list of things you can do
to keep characters interesting that
allows us to like them and once we start
seeing the nature of of the hero or
heroines major problem and the major
impossible task before them hopefully on
about page
six or eight we the audience the
audience becomes one person each of us
sitting alone and we project ourselves
psychologically project ourselves into
the hero and then we're along for the
ride and if that hero doesn't do
anything or doesn't want anything and
other people do all this stuff and all
the people to come in all the secondary
characters are the witty fun urbane you
know loquacious and they're they're that
and joking and funny they're all the
funny characters while basically your
central character is more or less
wallpaper it's it's dead
many things that story is not and it
also relates back to this idea that
story is better than the real so one of
the things that story is not is that it
is not a literal day in the life it is
not just a you know plod through the day
and I get my coffee and I wake up in the
morning and I go to work there's
something that there is a core action or
a core problem that is bigger or better
than the real that ties it int that that
can tie it into an everyday situation
but it's not just those little everyday
moments and I and I just wanted to throw
in there you know boyhood was my
favorite movie of the year and I think
that you know it breaks all of these
rules but the reason why it works is
that it's not just a day in the life or
recounting but it's just also this
device of having happened over 12 years
that makes it so so fascinating and so
there are exceptions to this rule but on
the whole these are the things that that
people should avoid when they're
approaching their stories another one is
random musings you know this is a you
know it seems to me where it's very
pretentious where you have some
characters sitting in a diner and
somebody goes ketchup what's that about
right that and then the movie just kind
of moves through people saying that and
you know it's funny to point out that
people think they're profound when
they're not once in a while but if your
whole movie is just kind of like ketchup
what's that about into the audience
after about 20 minutes if that long will
go what I'm do I need to be here for
this what is this and in it it feels
very pretentious kind of just fishing
around well these are just some people
who really they had one germ of an idea
but they really didn't think this
through it doesn't have any progression
stories also it's not a straight line it
needs to go up and down and around and
there needs to be highs and lows and I
like it in the same way that it's not a
day-in-the-life
it
not it's it's not just a straightforward
telling of events you know another one
is story is not a fascinating place or
even a really cool event so we get
pitches like this all the time people
like I'm going to write a story about I
have a movie about a nuclear submarine
getting stuck on the bottom of the ocean
and we go what's the story sorry they're
like uh nuclear submarines on the bottom
of the ocean it's like that's not a
story a story is when you start telling
me and what the character stakes are you
know with that you know so another one
is oh wow I went to this amazing village
in China and you know this is the
village where they make you know the
Dragons for the for the festivals it's
amazing and Mike's my movie is like that
village like that's not a story that's
an arena so we're constantly having to
help writers distinguish a really cool
arena you know or an interesting you
know kind of event from being a story
those things aren't stone tower or
Chicago in the 20s you know again great
a great arena but you have nothing until
you have your characters doing something
that's going to move your story forward
we have a structural tool called the
BMOC which is beginning middle obstacle
in climax these are the four points in
any great story where the hero is asked
to change and they're in every great
story whether it's Star Wars or The
Fault in Our Stars or a fast and furious
Tokyo Drift and these four points also
work inside every scene they're in every
action sequence this BMOC so this rhythm
of story is present in all great story
if you don't have good news bad news
raising stakes and and and ticking
clocks on every page of your story your
star is going to be boring but hardly
anyone teaches that a B in being
conscious of how those tools work is how
you start putting them on every page and
by the way these suspense tools work in
drama they work in romantic comedy they
work in every genre and they work in
television too if you go and look at a
tarantino script or you go and look at a
Chris Nolan script or you go and look at
Allen's script you will see on every
page once you've been shown it that
every page has ticking clocks every page
has good news bad news every page has
raising stakes a lot of them have other
suspense tools too but writers are often
unaware of this consciously they don't
build this into their stories when they
write them so just being aware that this
is how and they're cheap Trick's by the
way it's good news I'm giving you 20
bucks bad news I'm slapping you ticking
clocks is just a bomb a bomb ticking
down it's a gun pointed at someone these
are not sophisticated tricks they're
simple but the greatest artists use them
in all of their best work you've never
seen a Tarantino script that didn't have
three or four pointed guns in nearly
every scene it's cheap and it works like
a charm it entertains and that's why we
also see these in television
Breaking Bad is nothing but a series of
excruciating suspense devices so
excruciating
I couldn't even get sexy to watch it and
when you sit down to watch Breaking Bad
you often have to stop because it's so
repellant ly attention making but that's
what makes it great
the very beginning seriously coming up
with a good idea is the most important
thing and I was coming up with sort of
the basics onra ideas so I would run
like a basic cop story and that's fine
for television not fine for cinema where
it's all about the event it's all about
something being big and larger than
light so my ideas were like too small to
begin with and that I have a string of
scripts with like they're they're got
great scenes great characters but the
idea is way too small it's not it's not
involving and interesting enough for
people to spend 12 bucks to see the
movie on top of that whatever it costs
for the king-sized popcorn and the
king-sized drink you know it's a life's
fortune to go to the cinema these days
what I'm trying to come up with an idea
or write a script it's would this be a
movie that I would be in the audience
for and it's it's interesting that some
I know people that write scripts that
they would not go see that movie it was
made and I'm like why would you write
that then if you're not even the
audience for the movie so I try to write
a movie that's not the movie that I not
what I would want to see because really
what I want to see is the producer of my
last film spanked in public I read a
movie that is the kind of movie that I
would want to see that I would stand in
line to see that is you know that an
existing kind of movie that I'm sitting
in the audience for
they just don't bother to go deeper you
know what I mean you got to be original
I mean that's another thing originality
is very important you know because if
you read the same thing over and over
you're just going to not not gonna
respond to it you know so really that is
actually the bane of the writers
existence especially the screenwriter to
come up with something new I mean when
you think about I think in in the the
second edition of the 101 habits bill
marsilii one of the one of the
screenwriters there talks about doing
the 20s so for him like everything that
he thinks about any event any scene
character whatever he thinks of kind of
listing 20 different ways of doing it
like if it's like a you know talk about
the meet-cute writing a romantic comedy
how people meet in a cute way
well he's going to do 20 different
thoughts about it okay they can be this
I mean you have to do he does 20 because
the the first two or three or five of
them will be cliches will be things that
you know your automatic going to think
about them because they're the most
famous ones or the most that we've seen
a hundred times but but going deeper and
he forces himself to go deeper that's
where you get the creativity in the
originality and eventually when you
reach that past the 10 or 12 15 although
up to 20 you'll start getting some
really original ways because you force
yourself and so that's that's where the
writer needs to do you got to force
yourself to go deeper in order to create
some original writing right out of the
game it's a it's a tip that he uses a
you know habit of creativity to just do
the 24 anything you know 20 different
ways to rob a bank 20 different ways to
to say I love you 20 different ways to
break up with someone join different
ways to kill someone I mean there's all
these things that you've seen a hundred
times and when you see it over and over
you go you know you're you go cool you
know because you've seen it a hundred
times and it's only the really the
movies that breakout stories the stories
that break are the ones that are kind of
truly original right whenever you come
up with a unique angle to that story
that we all know the better for you
that's where we generality originality
comes and you know so and it gets harder
and harder because you know the more
the more the more romantic comedies
there is the harder it is to come up
with something new so you know my first
step in writing screenplays is coming up
basically coming up with a hundred ideas
and picking the best idea I have a thing
called 100 idea theory and it doesn't
nationally
doesn't have to be a hundred ideas but
if I come up with one idea that's one
idea it could be a terrible idea
if I come up with a hundred ideas or
sixty ideas or whatever I can comb
through and find the very best idea and
then I take it the Thunderdome
I take that idea and I go if I write the
script to this everyone's going to say
it's going to pick it apart so I'm going
to pick it apart first I want to find
all the flaws with whatever ideas the
idea is and try to get past those flaws
and remove them so that the idea is
great
naturalism is not naturalism and I'm
talking about for example dialogue that
has a lot of vocalized pauses urns and
arms and your nose and I mean and so on
we love that line stories better than
the real because one of the things that
we've figured out is the story is a
thing it's different than real life and
I mean you could you could talk about
that for ten years you know what does
that mean especially in the you know and
the realistic filmmaking you know phase
that you know we're seeing especially
the Indies but but the truth is that a
story isn't real life and in some ways
something's a story in every way in
which it's not real life right so in
real life people are mainly mysterious
to us they we don't know why they do
what they do we don't have access to
their motivations story is not like that
we do have access to their motivations
we do know what's driving them so
watching a story you get a little surge
of guilty pleasure because it gives you
something real life cannot legitimately
give you that you have no right to want
in real life so if a movie is when we
read a script is it doesn't give that
access if it doesn't clarify the motives
of the character really what they want
and what they need and what's driving
them is a bad story because that's one
of the things that people expect and
story that they're going for is access
you know an emotional access the problem
with real there are two problems with it
first of all it's available in the
streets for free you don't have to buy a
ticket and go into the movie theater or
hire a babysitter drive to the fee to
park the car pay for the ticket to see
what's real you can just step out into
the street and see what's real the other
thing is it what's real is more for the
most part I could tell you about my day
today everything that I could tell you
would be true
and contemporary and I really really
knew what I had for breakfast the route
that I took to get over to the campus
the context of three meetings this is a
big meeting day the first Wednesday in
the month so I was a tad bit to three
meetings today I love my colleagues and
I thank God every day that God placed me
in a face like this if you feel aware
where creativity is is happening and I'm
allowed to do creative work but these
were not terribly exciting meetings I
could walk you through the agendas of
those meetings and you'd be fast asleep
it's even though it's true and and it's
now again we want boredom in our lives
and we want to passion and excitement in
our art and another way that story is
better than the real is that the
settings are more interesting than our
everyday lives you know we don't go to
the movies to watch somebody you know in
the bathroom for an hour getting ready
for work you know that's that's our
everyday Monday in life we go to the
movies to see beautiful landscapes and
beautiful vistas and to see quirky
worlds and quirky arenas that are more
interesting than our everyday world and
similarly we took the characters in
movies we like them because there is
something just a little bit there
they're like us but they're just a
little bit better than us and that's the
that's the quality of a hero is somebody
who aspires to do the things that we
could grow up to do that are within
reach of what we could do but are just
you know they're just going a little bit
more beyond what we might be doing in
everyday life another way stories are
better than the real is that they're
structured around a theme they're
structured around some universal truth
about human life and this is not your
real life right you realize if I say to
you how did you learn you know what's
some big lesson you learned and you say
to me well I learned that it's important
to be truthful I learned this you know
by the time I was thirty that I wasn't
going to lie anymore it's like okay so
that means
probably had a thousand little incidents
from the time you were four and started
talking where you started to learn when
I lie I get in trouble you know and
having to juggle story telling and you
know and all of this stuff and so
finally at the age of thirty you go
hoeing I'm not going to lie anymore but
it's this cumulative thing that well in
a movie or in a story if it happens in
two hours there you take out all the
other lessons that people are learning
and you say we're just going to look at
how Luke learned that he needs to trust
the force
right you know in stars we're not going
to look at all Luke's other problems the
fact that he's a slob or he has issues
with women or that he's you know he's
got jealousy stuff no we're just going
to hone in on that so it's a very
unnatural structured around a theme
experience so when we read a screenplay
that it just seems to be all over the
place we say people this isn't going to
work as a story because the audience
doesn't get what are we talking about
here what is this about and that's one
at a big notes that we end up getting
all the time that the writer hasn't been
able to really say this story is about
this and so I'm going to eliminate
everything that isn't about that you
know it's a big idea that writer since
I've just never made that choice and so
the you stand back from the screenplay
and you say I don't know what this comes
down to in the end I don't know what
this is really about so a story is
better than real life because it gives
us it really cuts out everything that
isn't on your main universal truth and
story also has a resolution unlike real
life where it seems like we're always
waiting for our act 3 to happen we often
don't know what what resolutions are
going to be happening for us in our
everyday world but in a story it needs
to resolve and that that resolution
needs to be satisfying and it's the
satisfaction that comes from that
resolution that makes that story better
than what we normally go through in life
and then on top of that all the little
elements of story are better than real
life so dialogue you know in to write a
good line of dialogue sometimes it'll
take me
three weeks and then ten drafts later
I'm still tweaking that comeback think
about it as you have a fight with your
friend and then you sit there in the
shower kind of replaying that and you
keep coming all I should have said I
joined that line like that's what movies
are that they're the writer has gotten
that perfect response so you have this
perfect back-and-forth ref arte that
real life never has if any if people in
real life talk the way they do in the
movies these will be crazy people you
know but in the movies it's okay it's
expected you know in storytelling so the
idea of everything being honed to be
entertaining to be compelling to be a
feast it's a story is a feast as opposed
to just running through the frigerator
open the door and grab a few things
that's real life right but a story is a
piece and so that that's a we seen our
writers you know your your your what
you've done here just isn't feasting
enough it's just not better enough than
people's real life and you know we
always quote this one line when the
cinema verite movement was going through
the 50s everybody was trying to do some
realism realism realism mainly coming
out of Europe cuz they don't have any
money but Hitchcock the Great Master
said you know some people want movies to
be a slice of life I want two movies to
be a slice of cake you know and there it
is now that a movie is better than the
real and that it's a slice of cake and
and if it's we don't see it on the
screen on the paper because you're
trying too much to be gritty and real
then it's like why would anybody want to
do this and and then the last thing I
would say too is that your movie needs
to be at least as good as the real but
it needs to be better than the real so
in other words it can't be such that
people watch this movie and go wow
people don't talk like that that would
never happen or this is so far and it's
like they're right you know so those
those are signs that the script isn't
working that your movie as an even as
good as the real so you got a ten you
got to get to the real and then you got
to push it and be better than the real
everything's there to hear of their own
story and there's a little truth to it
but I gotta say I mean if I'm talking
from experience and from hearing
people's life stories that they want to
write as movies I would say about 90% of
them are not that interesting they just
the writers themselves think it's
interesting I don't think it is
interesting and audiences don't think
it's interesting so they got to learn
that the day that's why feedback comes
in if the feedback is okay well you know
I mean I always bring out Hitchcock's
quote about you know drama is real life
with all the boring parts cut out so a
lot of people feel that just because
they've had a few interesting
experiences may be unique that it warns
them to making a movie out of it they
may be right but a lot of times are not
are on the for emotions mad sad glad and
scared you haven't heard that one yeah
again there are they they are you know
there's a lot of variations or demands
meds ed glad and scared there's many
permutations and and dimensions there
but the way they are useful is like this
if you are building if you're outlining
something a section a particular section
here a goal sequence or a particular
scene the thing is the way you guarantee
that it's going to have conflict and
change in it and change is one of the
single most important is to talk about
that in a minute to change is the power
that makes screenplays either work or
not work
you got to quantify it but it can be
done wonderfully that if if the hero
lead character walks stomps jumps falls
into a scene and they are either mad sad
glad or scared by the end of the scene
they have to be one of the others if
they're mad when they show up they have
to be scared when they walk away or if
they're scared when they show up they
have to be glad when they walk away
because that guarantees dramatic change
within the scene and it's a way of
checking yourself because we read a
whole lot of scenes which are just talk
and they're the same everything is the
same at the end as as it was at the
beginning and that is not a viable scene
for visual storytelling
the thing you should be aware of is
human dynamics you know psychology
emotions character relationships that
you should be well-versed in now lucky
is the writer who has had amazing life
experience and had all those experiences
that he can write about that makes it
easier but it's not necessary if you're
a highly curious person I mean you know
you could be a great writer who's had a
very mediocre life you know I mean I'm
not I'm not a believer of the Hemingway
thing about you know if you want to
write about adventure you got a you got
a go and be adventurous and stuff I mean
maybe see there's some truth to it but I
think it really depends on your mind and
your curiosity you know and I think we
can all find you know it's all about
your imagination if you have if you're
highly imaginative you can you can write
about anything whether you experience it
or not you know if you write science
fiction you know George Lucas didn't
didn't experience going on a ship in
order to be able to write about it right
or James Cameron you know do you think
he'd think all that stuff about Pandora
and Avatar that he experienced that in
his own life no it's all imagination
right so that's what you need you need
you need to know you need to have high
imagination obviously but then you need
to know be well-versed in character
relationships so yes if you've had
experience recurrency relationships
that's great in character conflicts but
if you haven't you can always learn it
and if you're highly curious you know I
mean I've a psychology degree so so I
wasn't a writer I'd be a psychologist
because that's what fascinates me I'm
fascinated by human interactions given
psychology and especially the reason why
people do what they do which is what
characters doing stories so really you
know that works for me but my life story
as much as it was I considered very
unique and different from most people's
life stories I don't have the desire to
write about it so it doesn't affect me
at all in that in that sense
think the thing and that's a thing that
screenwriters have to do is scream
owners have to figure out how to get out
there in the world how to get out of
there for many reasons they have to
figure out how to get out of their home
and out of their comfort zone because
one of the things that happens is as we
shrink our world we shrink what we can
write about and we end up writing
stories you know as my two years in my
in my apartment after selling the script
we're just like smaller and smaller and
smaller stories because I was not
getting out in the world and being part
of the world and it's one of those
things where you you know life
experience is the is the raw material
for your scripts and the more life
experience you have whatever that is you
know broken hearts you know all that
stuff is all part of what makes you who
you are so you write the script but also
if you don't see the world out there
people often online that people will ask
questions research questions and they go
well how do I know about this and my
answer to that is you find the person
that does that for a living and you ask
them you don't ask me I'm a writer what
the hell do I know but if you want to
know about stuff you go out and ask
those people because part of that is you
get out of your comfort zone and into
the world but you also get the real
answers and so I get a script called
recall that was about the auto industry
and I went to when it existed the van
nuys GM plant and across the street was
a bar and I went into that bar and I
bought pitchers of beer and I asked guys
that worked on the assembly line just to
tell me about their lives and I got all
kinds of just stuff that I could never
get from Google never get from you know
going to library it was all stuff that
was their real life and one of the
things that made it into my script was
this guy that talked about how his hands
were so calloused that he was afraid to
touch his wife and I was a real
heartbreaking story it's like one of
those things that you don't think about
when you think about guys working an
assembly line you don't think that
there's going to be this thing that's
going to affect their the romantic
emotional life and those are the stories
the great story
by conflict you don't have to have a an
antagonist for conflict I mean most
characters in comedy are in conflict
anyway they're in conflict because
they're [ __ ] and so they're they're
in conflict with their co-workers or
their idiots and so they're in conflict
with the world around them or they're
like George and Seinfeld you know always
kind of downtrodden you know II or as it
were and so these in conflict with the
world and so the the best comedies
create characters that are intentionally
conflicting with either other people or
or the world or themselves what you
don't need is you don't need an
antagonist you can have an antagonist
but it's not necessary in Groundhog Day
there's no antagonist there's no villain
who's trying to thwart him it's just
that he's a jerk who you know everybody
kind of rolls their eyes about and then
he's stuck in this time warp ik how'd it
happen no one knows how do I get out of
it no one can help him so that's the
conflict of the premise actually
introduces a conflict the the company of
the catalyst and you usually want to
create that conflict in the protagonist
after you have successfully sketched out
the normal world don't don't start you
know it's not an action film don't start
or you could mean there's no you know
there's no rule that can't be broken but
you know don't start with something
crazy happening before I know who this
person is what's their normal world
what's what's what's the deal with them
what's the deal with how they live and
then you can create something that that
threatens that normal world again in in
in big there's a whole scene of him his
relationship with his best friend his
wanting to be with the little girl and
then the cat you know the conflict is
but now he's a 30 year old man what did
he want to do what does he do in in
Groundhog Day it's it's living the same
day over and over again and
and splashes you fall in love with a
mermaid but before that you want to take
the time to let me know what would this
guy be like what would the world be like
if that didn't happen take that you know
and is that two pages five pages ten
pages it's got to be what you need to
create the foundation of a real world
before the crazy world starts again
because the better your foundation the
better we're going to believe the
incredibly crazy things that are
happening in act three
teach you in film school or any writing
book is you know conflict is the source
of all drama if everybody if all your
characters are just getting along then
for ya nothing you know I look how long
are you so I mean I think there's a
tendency is a reason why most movies
over the last 20 years have adopted the
James Bond
opening which is just start with like
start with conflict from frame 1 so that
you can hold everybody's attention I
don't that's a good question I would
probably say that you know delaying
conflict too long or not not introducing
what the central conflict is going to be
can be a problem like for example I did
a film I did a short recently it was
like a 40 minute short and shorts are
harder because I think you know because
you have less time to establish
character and the movie that I'm was
making is a thriller called where's
Roman which I'm actually very very happy
about with it's kind of a surrealistic
thriller and the 3/4 of the movie is
really this one character venturing into
this very disturbingly weird hotel and
meeting all these characters and all
these terrible things happening to but I
wanted you to care about this character
before all this crazy [ __ ] happened so I
deliberately wrote a you know like a
five or so most a five or six minute
scene in a bar where you meet this main
character through another character and
it virtually is no conflict it's really
just two guys who like a strangers
Rangers meeting just having a
conversation about stuff and it was a
way of getting you to know who this guy
was and what a situation was and who he
was before all this stuff happened and I
think half the audience or the people
that watched it half for a little more
than half really appreciated that and
then I was rude I met another filmmaker
you know who's been around for years and
years years and said I really loved the
movie I would have cut down that
conversation at the beginning meaning
that he was saying you know get to the
get to the thing gets of the conflict
get to the conflict suit I think that's
the hardest thing for right
is to do is to try to establish a
character even through action and at the
same time getting the plot going which
tends to be when the conflict is is
established so the only danger of
starting with conflict too soon is that
you've got to maintain somehow maintain
this level of drama and that if you stop
that people are going to be accustomed
to a certain tension or a certain thing
and when you stop to smell the roses and
you may lose everybody but you know I
don't know that's that's that's what I
was thinking
one of the key skill sets in addition to
creative integration is they build the
right and compelling conflict and
compelling conflict is what takes great
characters and great dialogue and just
makes it pop off the page it's just it's
hard to explain that you have a you all
the visceral experience when you read
you can read you look you read some
stuff that's just bad and then you read
some stuff and it's got some great
moments and some great characters of
dialogue but it's nothing really
happening then you read some stuff and
it's it's good things are happening and
that's interesting but then you read
something and just pops off the page it
just you can tell I was a studio reader
and I could tell within one page if
someone knew what they were doing if it
popped off the page or not now that one
page was great I don't know if they
could write a whole script I have to
keep reading but if that one page didn't
pop I knew they couldn't and yeah if I
had a class of about 20 people they're
usually about two people and they're
writing just sort of popped off the page
more than others they didn't know why
necessarily but everyone could tell and
I think they could tell they would often
not say anything it's like in a writing
group there's usually one person who's
writing just is better than everyone
else I learn in an MFA program it's just
maybe people don't know why but it does
what I've learned is it's because
they're writing and compelling conflict
and I find that about 5% of the writers
that come to work with me naturally do
that I don't have to teach them it just
has that popping off the page and about
5% for to do that and the other 90% are
anywheres from they need some work today
they suck at it they just sucked at it
but you can teach people how to do it so
a great example is Neil Simon the
playwright he has a book called rewrites
which is his autobiography he talks
about like year after year when he was a
younger man he'd write these plays and
he loved the characters and in everyone
thought there was terribly funny but
there was just something missing it just
didn't hold together this wasn't
interesting enough and over time he's
like I know something's missing but I
don't know what it is and I know a lot
of writers who feel that way it's a
really terrible feeling he eventually
did the one thing he never wanted to do
is he went to his older brother who was
a really successful writer and his older
brother read his stuff and said
you're not writing a compelling conflict
and Neil Simon's like what are you
talking about what is this and he said
my older brother taught me what it was
and then the light bulb went off and so
then he said I would just structure my
compelling conflict and then pour in all
the character and comedy and that's how
he did his career David Mamet and this
was on my website or you can look online
he did a memo about a decade ago or so
to the writers of the unit his TV show
and he basically said you will learn how
to write in compelling conflict or
you'll be in the blanking unemployment
line or the bread line and a lot of
f-bombs in this memo but he's basically
saying this is not a natural skill set
for most people you will learn to do
this or you will not survive
any story you can talk about epic poem
you can talk about a myth you can talk
about a fairy tale or children's book
they're all built on character desire
and conflict every story that I can
think of almost without exception if
it's a narrative story that has a
beginning middle Emma and just going to
about it be about a character who
desperately wants something and
something stands in their way
too little conflict in any story or too
little tension and the story is going to
be really boring and nobody's going to
be interested I think you need to have
conflict and tension almost if not in
every scene of your book pretty much in
every scene even things that are
character driven I always think you want
to look for how can you ramp up the
tension in that even if it's just a
dialogue exchange you try to have
moments that are ratcheting up the
tension so a good example of that is
something like in the beginning of the
shining the movie I also loved the book
with the film there's a scene where it's
um the mom talking to Child Protective
Services so you're learning information
about the fact that the father may have
been abusive toward to the son but it's
just a dialogue scene but the whole time
she's smoking a cigarette and the ash
just gets longer and longer and you're
like oh my god ash your cigarette you
get so tense for her you're like that's
going to fall all over you and she
doesn't and it just somehow is this
genius way of just keeping tension so
there's always little things you can
look at in a scene to kind of keep the
tension going and then obviously there's
big conflict scenes where there's a
fight or actually something major
happening or a major obstacle but I
think throughout a story that's what
keeps you reading and people will be
like oh it's getting worse it's getting
so much worse for these characters and
you know or even like a book series like
Game of Thrones you're like oh my god
things are still happening and happening
but it's like that's what keeps the
story going you know a story about
conflict is a really boring story
I think Ravana get famously said make
great characters and then make bad
things happen to them
one exercise that we do with our clients
is we have them make a list of every
possible conflict that could ever happen
to their character and and then you know
try to come up with 20 things and then
we say okay now come up with 10 more and
then come up with 10 more and now put
them put it all in your script see how
much conflict you can add to your script
and that's a really common beginner
mistake is that there's just simply not
enough conflict happening in the story
and high stakes lots of conflict that's
what drives a story so you know it
should so something should happen on
page 1 yeah
or the conflict is only as one nature to
me that's the mistake so many Hollywood
studio films today that the conflict is
all external conflict you know or the
world is ending the world ending yeah
you know so we need to superheroes to
come in and and you know stop with that
guy
but know that there's all kinds of
different levels of conflict you know
between human beings there's a
psychological oscillate between yourself
between you and and the gods or the fate
you know and and and so the idea is what
the nature of the conflict in your
script if you only have external
conflict coming at your character one
kind of you know like literally like
somebody's everybody's throwing stones
at them then then it's a boring movie
you need to have all different kinds of
conflict you need to see a physical
emotional spiritual every every type of
yeah so things story is not something
without conflict you know stories about
conflict and and the essential conflict
in a story by the way is the conflict
between what a character wants and what
they need so you know the character says
I want to be an astronaut they need to
be somebody who can be dependent you
know interdependent with other people so
the movie ends the story ends when those
two things meet when when they're want
becomes their real need so their want
begins to transform it's like it's not
about being an astronaut that I should
want it's this thing as soon as the
character wants what they really should
want the story's over but that kind of
trying to get those two things to
converge what they want and what they
need that's the fundamental conflict
many music and when a main character
gets what they need that's typically a
happy ending when the main character
gets what they want that's typically a
tragedy
the problem is there is no adversary or
there is no powerful adversary adversary
is so critical people need to work on
their adversary until it is the
adversary should be the strongest person
in the story and I you know when I was
coming up is they oh they have to be
equal they have to be equal in power to
the hero no they have to be much more
powerful than the hero it has to look
for most of the movie it has to look
like the hero has no bloody way of
defeating this adversary or surmounting
this the the problems being presented by
this adversary but they do it they they
clink them and they out try them and
drive and they can make it happen and
that's a story with great conflict with
a hero who is doing things who sucks us
in emotionally that we can ride along
happily for the journey and that's how
that's how the good ones work
what roger ebert used to call the idiot
plot where the thing is if two
characters just said what they know to
each other the movie would be over in
five seconds pretty much and so
basically what it is is you have a
character that is being forced by the
writer not by not by in real life and
real life they would say something but
if the writer realizes if they say it
the movies over in five minutes or now
this thing goes in a different direction
so they don't say those things they keep
them to themselves which plays false
instead we want to do is we want to have
the and this is this is the thing often
people they're afraid to create the
conflict because the conflict gets into
the messy stuff and so they hold back on
the conflict when we need to get into
that conflict they there's a thing that
another another screenwriting problem is
delaying things because we you know will
that conflict really can't happen until
this point or this point psychic camera
this point in the movie when we're at
this point
well what usually happens is they they
stall until they get to that conflict
when instead what they should do is have
that conflict happened here and then
have things just continue to get worse
so that's seeing here instead of being
the you know the the beginning of the
conflict instead is when the conflict is
a hell of a lot worse they don't
escalate the conflict enough an
escalating conflict is important again
it's an in dialogue it would seem false
if that character didn't say there's a
problem and here's what it is or you
know I have an issue with you and they
need to have that issue it needs to be
it needs to start here
you know the fuse needs to not just be
lit but then it needs to explode and
that explosion has to start a chain
reaction of other explosions so that's
it's like an act to problem often it's
writers try to not try to hold
everything off until act two when you
need to kick off with you know with
something exciting happening
the first thing before you even start
writing the words of the scene you want
to step back and as usual my suggested
vices ask questions in other words first
of all you should have already asked the
questions who is my hero
what is the hero's wound what are they
afraid of what is their visible goal
that they're going after and where
structurally does the scene occur
because depending on how far along in
that inner journey the character is
that's going to affect how they would
react in the situation after you figured
those things out then the next question
you want to ask is what does my
character want in this scene and does
that desire is that desire going toward
ooh they think it's going to move them
closer to their goal or at least
overcome an obstacle to achieving their
goal if the answer to that question is
no then the scene should be jettisoned
it's not serving the story because every
scene has to move the character closer
to their visible goal or force them to
face an obstacle or anticipate an
obstacle that they didn't know they were
going to previously so let's say the
answer is yes though you do know that
this is going to contribute to the goal
and you figure out what do they want to
accomplish within the scene what do they
where do they want to be or what do they
want to have happen to the end of the
scene then what are they going to do to
try and do that that will constitute the
action of the scene the dialogue you
just set aside until all these other
things are figured out because the
dialogue is only really to reveal in
some way how they're feeling about the
situation or its dialogue where they're
trying to persuade somebody to do
something or get above somebody else
take control of the situation and so on
but first you want to see what does the
character want in the scene and then
what is the obstacle they must face in
the scene to achieving that because the
motion of a movie and the emotion of any
scene is primarily going to grow
out of the conflict if it's not the
conflict being faced right then it's the
conflict that they are anticipating or
occasionally that the audience is
anticipating in the thriller we may know
that the killer is in the next room and
all the hero wants to do is get to the
kitchen to make a sandwich but it's
still it's still about what do they want
and what are we anticipating is going to
get in their way
and then when it comes to dialogue
especially if you struggle the dialogue
get get something down you should get
anything down to begin with just so
you've got to seem to work with rather
than a blank page but if you don't know
what the dialogue should be right
dialogue where the character is just
saying how they feel and what they want
it's what's known as on-the-nose
dialogue it's terrible dialogue but at
least now you've got a scene you've got
action you've got character you got
dialogue and now you can ask the last
question there would be my suggestion
that is okay now I know what they want
they're going through this action how
can I make it more difficult for them
first of all but also instead of having
them announce their feelings or desires
can they do it without saying anything
or if they in a conversation how can
they hide their true desires or feelings
and cover it up with more surface
superficial subtextual language and
that's sort of what you're going for and
those are sort of the beats of going
through it then it's a matter of just
going through that process again and
again and again with each successive
draft but that will that will get you to
something if you're looking at that
blank page to begin with so it's good
Michael oh thank you you're very welcome
huh I'm going to write that down
wanna movie to me is constantly
interesting
I was totally engaged by imitation game
from beginning to end they were able to
comment on some very very weighty and
difficult issues without ever getting
preachy or intellectual about it
bully bullying homophobia uh issues
involving the war and peace in life and
death should we tell these people that
they're about to you know the Nazis
arooo with the u-boats are about to sink
this convoy and we can save all the
lives are the people in the convoy that
way but that will also tell the Nazis
that we're on to their code and that'll
they'll change the code and we won't be
able to read them anymore and that will
cost more like these are very
interesting questions and their answer
in a dramatic context without ever
becoming a lecture about principles or
[Music]
protocols or anything like that now
there's nothing wrong with with lectures
on principles and protocols but movie is
not the place for that
of writing this is getting back to that
assumption thing we're talking about
before which we deal a lot with and I go
back to write your life I'm telling you
a story about a traumatic experience I
had it's for instance say personal
experience and I'm going to assume that
if I tell you everything that happened
you're going to have the same emotional
reaction I did that's a huge assumption
you may not a writer can write a script
it may be true may be personal may be
totally fiction but the right of writing
that script and all those characters is
having an emotional experience as he or
she is creating it with these characters
how they related to each other all the
twists and turns in the story and they
going oh that's great that's great
assuming that anybody else reading it
will be having the same reaction that
may not be true so that the assumption
of the writer is a problem can be a
problem the best way to deal with that
is really simple you tell the writer
there's your problem
you wrote that scene and you're very
moved by it
I read the scene I don't get it okay
what you're intending is great I'm not
getting it and other people are not
you're assuming it would get in because
you are so identified with those
characters in that situation okay not a
problem let's figure out how we can make
it clearer to the honest so the audience
does get it and that's my job as a
director that's my job as a directing
consultant or a writing consultant is to
help writers get to that point where the
scene is clear and note one thing which
we don't need to talk a lot about but
one thing is a script
speaking of script and writer a script
initially in order to get made into a
movie has to engage the reader and as
you know the reader very often is not
the person who's going to produce it the
reader is somebody down the line in some
production company whatever it does you
in other words that script by itself by
its little self those 120 pages has to
impact that reader so the first thing is
let's make sure the reader gets it the
reader who just picks up another script
and
reading gets it that's really crucial
so forget me the director and forget all
the other people we got it we got to
make sure that the script is strong
enough that that works and if it's not
doing it then it's not going to get made
and the writer can deal with his for his
or her frustration like why can't they
get it don't go there don't go why can't
they get it let's go back to how good
this is what a lot of people like
Michael Haig and Chris logo and all
those people teach screenwriting work
with writers on is not lots of times
it's not about what the story is about
how do you craft these scenes and
characters and certainly that the writer
will get it and eventually all the other
people who are going to work on it
I'm just going to make this up I had
this bout with cancer and I fought off
cancer together robbed me of a year of
my life but now I'm a cancer survivor I
could tell you about it and you should
feel horrified by what happened because
I didn't frightened and someone could
tell me that I go OK it's not it's not
going to impact me the way you think it
is only because you as you tell it we
reinstate filter of assumption the
filter of assumption of a writer even
writing fiction I created this great
moment in the scene and nobody gets it
well and we have to keep working on it I
understand what you're going for I
understand what you want them to get you
haven't crafted it in the way for them
to get it so it's also understanding not
only from a writer's point of view not
only understanding their layer or
barrier of assumption and because every
screen rod I just think this is really
true finishes the screenplay thinks it's
brilliant hopefully they do why
otherwise why do it and that's an
assumption too but also they have to
realize that every reader has barriers
against certain things that you have to
plow through you have to break through
you have to surprise them you have to
sort of find your way around the
barriers and obstacles that the reader
has within themselves so yes you have to
understand yourself and you have to
understand you can't say why don't you
get that you have to understand they
they don't get it for a reason
I teach I am the home of TMI I come in
and vomit everything going on in my life
be a good bad tragic happy I I am I am
an open book if I'm being completely
honest a cuz it's free therapy and I
have a captive audience of 20 people but
it's also because I hear here when I
went to one of the great sages and of
all time and with a view of the human
condition Jimmy Page from Led Zeppelin
said said I never want to be respectable
I always want to be responsible and I
love that quote and I hope after the
first class that people take with me
they know they're not going to get
respectable at all I can i I will I will
again I will tell too much and there is
a little bit of method to my madness
though because because I don't want
because I know writers directors and put
themselves on that pedestal because
they've had this degree of success and
they feel that they have to come in and
be very buttoned down and very above the
people that they're talking to we're
talking down to I don't look at it like
that at all I will tell you about my bad
night my hangover my whatever but but
and part of it again it's like free
therapy but part of it is also this is
this is my life and end where and it
sometimes it's not terribly respectable
but I'm responsible because I'm
responsible because I will get my ass to
my computer and right and don't worry
about being perfect but that is a debt
that I wish I could say that
that my success rate was a hundred
percent with that but again most people
will never finish their scripts because
that sense of that needing to be perfect
oh I'm being boring oh this isn't gonna
this isn't working it will take over and
it will crush their creativity and it's
a very sad thing the witness I try to
get people over it I try to say look
it's a first draft I tell you no don't
worry so much but but that is the
toughest job any person who's teaching
any kind of creativity has is to
convince people to get out of their own
way and my way of doing it again is to
say today students I am a hot mess but I
wrote but I but I wrote for four hours I
just don't you know I I you know i-i've
knock wicker I've made a living at this
for thirty years I mean it's insane
sometimes great sometimes skating by
sometimes whatever but it hasn't come
out of being perfect believe me but it's
coming out of of having that enough
discipline to write always don't need to
be respectable always be responsive in
pain any pay wow thank you
go back to Sean Ryan again the one who
was so promising and he got a job on a
sitcom as soon as he came to LA and then
he didn't work for six years and what he
did is he wrote and I think that he
wrote about 14 spec scripts and what
happened is his scripts were all good
but nothing was getting him traction and
he asked his manager he said to his
manager send me an example of a script
that is getting somebody work and his
manager sent over the script that had
the most buzz at the time and Sean
compared it page to page and said he'd
have you know three things on a page
that were really good but this one the
one that got the buzz every single beat
was perfect and when he realized that he
had not been hitting the mark he started
to write and hit the mark and in not too
long a time he got hired on the show and
that show led to another show and then
he got he developed the shield so you
just have to keep working you know I
suspect it was about four or five years
in that that happened so he was only
writing that next level of script for a
couple of years I don't know the exact
dates but I know that story
and how do you test out a screenplay you
test it out by getting people to sit
around a table or at least half of them
sitting around the table reading parts
and the other half of them sitting
around the table drinking wine it's
important eating eating some cheese and
listen and and don't get actors together
don't rehearse them that would be the
death of it what you want is you want a
si si experience sick is the Latin word
for as is you just want to hear the
script as is without trying to make it
better because if something works on the
page in the mouths of you know maybe
just another writer not another trained
actor you know it's alive and if
something's flat then you know
something's wrong and and then the the
hard task is to not to wake up to the
coma that that writers put themselves in
when they hear their script being read
out loud
and try to try to do what you need to do
in order to in order to fix it
from beginning to end the least we want
is not to be bored I mean I go to the
movies and see screeners scandalously
I'm going less and less the theaters and
looking more and more screeners I used
to feel guilty about not going to the
theaters now I feel guilty about not
screening the screeners and and the
reason is usually I am bored I think
most art is is pretty bad most paintings
most sculpture the most literature most
music is lousy now that also may seem
like a cynical and a dark thing to say
but it's the opposite of that the truth
is that the the stuff that is
contemporary much of it is going to be
pretty bad some of it will be brilliant
what happens is that it the bad stuff
falls away you go I was in New York not
too terribly long ago and I was in the
Museum of the Metropolitan Museum of Art
one of my favorite museums and I didn't
see a single painting there that wasn't
timeless and eternal that didn't deserve
to be there
and you could get the impression from
that that the paintings are somehow
worthy all the time well you don't
realize a lot of people don't realize is
that for every painting that hangs at
the Met there are 10,000 stupid
worthless jerky amateur paintings now
there's nothing wrong I think it's one
of other people tried to paint and tried
to be creative and took a shot at it
but it's unusual that it's worth
bothering somebody else about that is to
say there's something in the work that
merits the attention and the
consideration of the time of an audience
an observer in film because it is
contemporary even more so television
because it's in our face now there
hasn't been the chance for the stuff the
bad stuff to drop away so we think that
it's uniquely bad when it isn't it's
just as bad as other as other art
fortunately the little bit of really
really good stuff is enough to change
your life and and make it worth engaging
all of it all of the stuff so that you
do see the the good stuff
there's people people say why don't they
make good movies now like they used to
in the 30s and the 40s
did they make good movies in the 30s and
the way they did there were a lot of
really good ones but there were also a
lot a lot of lousy ones we just don't
remember them I think 50 60 years from
now they'll be saying why don't they
make good movies like they did back in
the early you know new millennium
because the people will have forgotten -
The Hunger Games
I'm not a big fan of the things I think
people are going to forget about it
but they're going to remember the
imitation game that we're into games
today I guess the least we want when I
say don't be boring I'm saying that's
the very least that I want from a work
of art we're talking now about dramatic
narratives you know he's I was at the
Louvre in Paris and I saw the Mona Lisa
among others how much time did I spend
with it a minute if I'd spent 3 minutes
with it that would have been a long time
if I sat quietly now for just a few
seconds you'd feel how how how heavily
time ways Keith no I'm just waiting for
see if I get quite in for two seconds
you get nervous in return and I don't
blame you that's my that's my point I
say sorry uh no no no not at all that's
you help you you're helping me the the
but the most we want from that's the
least we want I have a deal with my wife
which is if I start to nod out during
movie she's supposed to let me do that
unless some snoring and wheezing and
spraying everybody around us and then
bringing disgrace in discredit and
humiliation upon us it's up to the movie
to keep me awake and
the fact that matter is that I used to
like fight it if I started to drift
during the movie I would fight it like
you know hates so what a I got the
breath and China you know petitions now
I if I start to drift that's it I'm
going to nod out in this one it just
does not worth seeing you know I've
walked into movies where I was really
weary hadn't slept very well but it was
a good movie and it woke me up
so that's the least we want don't be
boring and if that's what you do that's
an incredible achievement
but again that's the bottom that's
what's the top and the top is I want my
life changed completely the way great
art does I want it turned upside down
and transmogrified I want to be
transported and that's what Breaking Bad
did to me that's what the Sopranos did
to me I just my life is different and
you know constantly because of my
exposure to to that that great art and
that's what great art should do at the
top end it should just change your life
forever
how do you know if you have blazing-hot
material your phone is ringing people
want to meet you they want to take you
out for lunch they want to take you to
dinner they want you to come over to the
barbecue they want to buy your material
or hire you to work on their projects
there's a buzz about you in town if you
don't have representation agents and
managers are sort of knocking on your
door everybody sort of kissing your butt
and saying how fabulous you are and you
feel really fabulous that's blazing hot
material when you get traction that's
how you know it's blazing hot and
there's people that aren't in LA they're
not in the business and they feel like I
could write a fantastic script let's say
and and it'll never get into the right
persons hands if I'll never get
discovered if you have blazing hot
material that really will and even if
you know somebody who knows somebody who
knows somebody who can get your script
to somebody it's like six degrees of
separation if that material is blazing
hot you will be discovered absolutely
and what happens is if your material has
been out in the marketplace for three or
four months and nothing is happening you
can fool yourself by saying you know
what they just don't get it
it didn't get to the right person but
the truth is it's probably not ready yet
it's time to go back to the drawing
board and you wouldn't be the first
person that that had to happen for that
happens to most people because you don't
come out of the chute being perfect I
think that that's a lot of people's
misconceptions especially screenwriters
is my first thing it's going to sell
it's going to be great again
there's the Mickey Fisher phenomenon
occasionally it happens but that's
really rare that's really rare writing a
really kick-ass script and putting it in
front of somebody and making the first
page so good that they have to keep
reading to page five
and making the first five-page is so
good they have to keep reading to page
10 and making the first 10 page is so
good that they never put it down until
they get to the last page and they have
to pick up the phone and call you as
soon as they're done that's how good
your script has to be and it can't be
that good that you can't think it's that
good all your friends have to read it
and think holy [ __ ] this is the best
thing I've ever read can I say that on
your yippee we're on the internet right
have you please little hands right for
them okay and and then your friends have
to show it to their friends and people
who don't even know you have to read
this and think this is the best thing
I've ever read I can't wait to see this
on television or in the movies and when
you have a script that's getting that
kind of reaction from your friends then
you can walk into somebody's door and
say here this is what I can do read this
and you will hire me and you'll have
that confidence to go into the room and
exude that and if you have that
confidence people will read that first
page if you walk into somebody's office
and you feel that way about your
material and you know without a shadow
of a doubt that this is a great script
that gets across to people and they'll
read your first page but if your first
page is amateurishly written they're
going to stop right there
not afraid of being boring because I I
just I I will jump off creative cliffs
and I and sometimes I'll land really
hard and break my neck and sometimes
I'll lend exactly where I need to land
but boring isn't an issue for me and
it's interesting because I've been at
this a long time now and I feel more
unborn than ever I feel I feel
creatively Unleashed some of it is I
have nothing to prove I've got some cool
posters and a couple of classics and all
of that but I'm not I'm not ever worried
about boring I am worried about good and
that's a different thing and good that
it's going to resonate and and and that
people are going to feel it and that's a
different thing not but not boring but
being good I worry about every day when
I write and I'm very I'm I'm my hardest
harshest critic and sometimes that gets
in the way at a little bit I I wish I
could go to bed not analyzing and
reanalyzing what I wrote that day but
maybe that goes with the territory
but yeah I always wanted I want to be
better than good and and I wasn't you
know and and again it's sort of silly
and maybe arrogant as it sounds and like
when I was starting Beatle just with
Michael we're going to write a classic I
want everything I do to be great and you
don't always do that I'm not even
pretending that you always do that but
good isn't good enough ever for me and
boring doesn't enter into it now let's
just have some sexy sensual fun sure but
you know what you're doing then you say
okay now it's time to light candles
important line and let's have fun but
you don't you're not stuck in any
particular place